[Musique]
la torpeur matinale s'est vite
transformée en cauchemar pour beaucoup
d'entre eux dans les parcs sur un
pompier sur la route du travail pendant
près de 5 heures ils ont cherché à
tremper la mort
Olena pensait avoir fui le danger en
quittant la ville occupé de Kerson au
sud du pays elle est en colère
je crois que les Russes sont des bâtards
dit-elle c'est ça ils veulent détruire
notre peuple nos infrastructures tout je
suis vraiment fâché
l'illusion de sécurité a volé en éclat
les stations de métro sont redevenues
des abris Antibes où on se donne un peu
de courage on fredonnant des air
patriotiques
selon la défense ukrainienne l'armée
russe a lancé plus de 80 ici sur
l'Ukraine depuis les airs la mer et la
terre des dizaines de drones shahides
des drones kamikazes ont aussi été
déployés sur tout le pays
ils vivent tout à l'ouest largement
épargnés par des combats lointains s'est
retrouvés sous les tirs ni pro centre du
pays a aussi été secoué par des
explosions meurtrières la corrigea sa
population ciblée encore et encore
depuis trois jours
au-delà des morts et des blessés des
civils ciblées en plein heure de pointe
les infrastructures énergétiques du pays
ont été lourdement endommagées des
villes entières sont privées doux et
d'électricité encore ce soir certaines
presque entièrement l'Internet ne
fonctionne pas dans bien des régions
pour pallier le stress imposé par les
attaques sur son réseau énergétique
l'Ukraine a décidé de mettre fin à ses
exportations d'électricité vers l'Europe
dès mardi Vladimir Poutine a été claire
il est temps pour l'Ukraine de rendre
des comptes pour l'explosion sur le pont
qui relie la Russie à la Crimée une
humiliation pour lui
par ses actions le régime de Kiev c'est
deux facto alignés avec les formations
terroristes internationales avec les
groupes les plus odieux à-t-il dit
laissez de tels crimes sans réponse ni
tout simplement plus possible le
président russe promet des répliques
sévères en cas de nouvelles attaques
ukrainiennes contre la Russie il pourra
compter plus que jamais sur l'appui de
son homologue Alexander Loukachenko le
président du Bel qui avait jusqu'ici
résisté aux pressions de Moscou annoncé
un retour massif de soldats russes au
bélarusky a qualifié les attaques
multiples d'actes terroristes une dure
journée pour son pays a-t-il concédé à
ses concitoyens ils cherchent à semer la
panique et le chaos ils veulent détruire
notre système énergétique ils sont
désespérés a-t-il dit c'est une escalade
inacceptable de la guerre selon le
secrétaire général des Nations unies
Antonio gutieres des frappes insensées
qui ont toutes les apparences d'un crime
de guerre selon l'Union européenne
c'est bombardements interviennent alors
que la Russie enchaîne les revers et les
déconvenues depuis le début de septembre
en Ukraine perdant du terrain dans le
sud comme dans le nord-est du pays ici
Marie-Eve Bédard Radio-Canada qui elle